hey um here's a caller who is trying to
make me feel
shame about the size
of my subscriber base 2192 david p
is the number take a listen to this hey
dave your show is so pathetic 970
subscribers
now this is not a boston accent there's
a rhode island accent it's sort of like
the boston accent's little brother
important to distinguish just from the
standpoint of geography
uh but what is this 970 subscribers
what's he talking about
my god i don't know how you get the
balls to be so freaking stupid
the balls yeah yeah
you got more subscribers inviting
spiders got bullets
unbelievable you suck so bad i'm only
watching you because uh youtube
shut them down anybody know what on
earth that guy is talking about
900 subscribers we have over 9
000. we actually we have one point uh
what do we have 1.3
1.4 million on youtube anyway that's our
friend from rhode island appreciate you
tuning in we've got a great bonus show
today we'll talk about rent prices
soaring as people are going back to
cities
we'll talk about a safe consumption site
the first in the u.s
and a really unusual decision by a court
relating to fda approval all of those
stories and more
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com